good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet so
to help you on your journey today's
message is use fear over to you Tony
Robbins the only way to deal with fear
that I found in my life is a couple ways
one of those ways is to turn it on
itself and ask yourself what am I afraid
of I'm free of that I got to be more
afraid of what I'm gonna miss out on
missing out on my mission this thing out
who I'm supposed to be missin in other
words if you're not get get rid of fear
than use fair use fear or it uses you
it's that simple so you gotta say okay
what's the price if I just stay doing
this what's the price what do I need to
really even get scared if I learn all
this I don't follow through that's
something to be scared about
and then that fear will get you over
your fear it'll push you through turn
fear in itself second way you can do it
is use what you've probably heard me say
because I've used this number 17 is my
little rocking chair test right I'm
gonna I'm gonna sit myself in my rocking
chair I'm I'm 85 years old and looking
back on my life and I say I didn't do
this or I did so I like to use fear in
two different ways the first is the
rocking chair test it's will I regret
this when I'm on my deathbed when I'm 80
90 100 250 years old however long we're
living at that point of future will I
regret this and that was something that
I learned when I was 18 19 years old and
it's been one of the most powerful
lessons that has had an impact on me
that I had this moment in my life I've
talked about Paris and the girls story
that I had before and from there I
decided I don't want to live with regret
like I could deal with short-term pain
but I can't deal with not knowing and
that led me to join the startup company
and ever since if I come across the
situation and I'm gonna feel like I'm
gonna regret it
like I want to say yes but I'm really
afraid because of whatever short-term
impact there might be I just make the
longer term fear bigger than the
short-term fear
so I'm more afraid to miss out on a
lifetime of opportunity versus the
short-term fear of it not working out
and if you can catch yourself when you
feel those moments of I'm just finding
practical reasons why I shouldn't do
this but really is just fear I find that
that really helps me thinking about the
long-term and whenever I have a major
decision that I'm unsure about I imagine
my life on my deathbed rocking chair
tests looking back and we're gonna
regret this and if it if it's yes if I'm
gonna regret not taking action then I
know I have to take action
however scary that may be short term the
second thing that I use fear for is
building the muscle my muscle building
test and that's where I want to get used
to being uncomfortable I want to get
used to if I'm afraid of something not
just always shrinking down and the
hardest part I think for most people is
to catch it because again we come up
with these rational reasons for why we
shouldn't do something we're really it's
just that fear speaking out so
understanding the why behind the why
really really important and the more you
say yes to those things the more you
stretch your comfort zone just for the
fact that you were afraid of doing it
the more that muscle is gonna build and
I've shared a number of different
examples in different videos of me you
know dancing on the street and being
afraid of what people would say about me
or me trying to do snowboard jumps and
being afraid of what people would say or
look at me or even here walking making
making a video this is not a green
screen somebody commented before what
green screen are you want I'm not on a
green screen this is the actual business
that I own charnota and salsa that's the
natural window there's real people
walking behind and at the start that can
be intimidating right that people are
walking behind sometimes people like
look in and see what's happening and I
have to worry like are they are they
judging me but the fact that I'm afraid
of that means that I have to go out and
do it just to see it just to get rid of
that fear and then what that does is
expands my comfort zone so that the next
time I do it it's not as scary and the
next time it's not as scary and the next
time you lose the fear so I'm not afraid
to come here now and speak with people
walking by but if you constantly allow
fear to beat you then even the smallest
things you're going to shrink down from
and when you have opportunities that can
serve you
higher purpose I can make a great life
for yourself you're not gonna do them
because you're too afraid because you
just live in this tiny little bubble so
you can continue to expand like the
great things happen at the edge of your
comfort zone so if you can continue to
expand your comfort zone more and more
and more great things are going to
happen to you and so just recognizing it
whenever you can catch that fear it can
make a big difference if you decide to
say yeah is to step into the fear to
lean in on it and just do it even though
you are afraid so those two tests the
rocking-chair tests look forward if
you're gonna regret it for the rest of
your life then you have to say yes you
have to have the certainty you have to
know and deal with short-term potential
failure for not working out versus the
long-term you know for the rest of your
life feeling like you're living with
regret and to just building the muscle
recognizing that the great things happen
to the edge of your comfort zone and the
more you practice stretching your
comfort zone the more great things are
going to happen to you so the question
date today is I'm curious how do you use
fear how have you use fear to help you
in your business in your life I'd love
to hear an example if you want to share
it please put it down the comments below
and also if you're responding with a
comment in the first couple hours of
this video going live you have a chance
to win one of our two daily prizes I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Serge Berber off Serge thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word and taking that picture and
post into Twitter
I really really appreciate the support
man and I'm so glad you enjoyed the book
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso
let's pray so give me go
when you experience moments of
self-doubt how do you approach getting
out of that dark place I grandiose my
way out of fear if you can imagine that
it's a good way you know I it's like
literally it's like okay I'm gonna do
one of the greatest car chases of all
time and if I don't I'm not as talented
as I thought I was and I will realize
that there is a ceiling to my talent
right now I don't think there is but if
I don't do but if it's not one of the
greatest car chases of all time then I
failed and I there is a ceiling in my
talent I'm not as good as I thought I
was and I said that to everybody and was
I scared
yeah you're right I had trepidation
going all the way because it's mine to
fail and it's my nubium and it's failing
in front of the mirror too because I
don't know if I did it or not and I'll
be like okay yeah you are not as good as
you thought you were and that got me to
Mount Everest if it's true number one
point he goes Robert can you imagine you
and me doing this car chase together how
great it's gonna be in a mic game you're
on your own brother five hundred mile an
hour Bulls we want to live the vanishing
point dream buddy live it he did it all
by himself and I'm so impressed there is
a scene in there where you talked about
bullies and running from danger and
things like that when you were trying to
help this kid yeah what happens is this
boy is being harassed by the
neighborhood bully and his father is
encouraging his son to beat up this
little boy mm-hmm and I wrote this scene
I wrote this particular scene in the
script and I was trying to think what
can I write to encourage this boy to
handle this situation you know with this
bully in the neighborhood and I'm and
I'm spending days trying to hear what
can I say
to boy and finally I came up the answer
and it was a situation that I as a child
had encountered about his age I went to
a school in Arizona that was mostly
Indians from the reservation and there's
this one Indian kid who just didn't like
me and every day he chased me home from
school
and and I'd had to run by this gas
station and this mechanic could watch me
being chased by this Indian kid every
day and finally he just couldn't handle
it anymore and he stopped me and made me
face this boy and I told him I said you
know I'm I was told I'm scared and and
he says well and the money said to me
which is pills still true which I
remember is that he says you know that
running from your fear is more painful
than facing it and that's something I've
always remembered and in this one I
relate to this boy and of course
eventually he has to face this figure in
the film I see you in your basement like
like a Batman with all machines and it's
really precise I guess and really what
you put you know what you put and then
you go live yes what's the difference
risk the risk you know and and the risk
and I have stage fright you know and I
never confronted the risk or when I did
come from I mean Belgium you know 2000
year 2000 that was you have no idea but
it took them to get me to do it no no no
no I had a thousand I had a thousand
excuses why not to turn there finally I
did it and it was exquisitely horrifying
that's the only way I can fort complex
yes it was very very very complex and
what was really good was right in the
beginning within like two seconds
I played just the worst wrong note and I
could either stop and cry or I could
laugh all right and it didn't kill me
and nobody else out there
nobody was throwing anything you know it
was fine thank you
to the people of Ghent for not killing
me and giving me the courage and you
know and the the absurdity you know you
have to be able to laugh at yourself and
you have to learn how to laugh at
yourself